House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones successor
show that will air in 2022 on HBO.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s Targaryen
history book Fire And Blood volume 1 and on
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
The man who started it all, King Aegon I Targaryen,
known as Aegon the Conqueror
and Aegon the Dragon, was the founder and
the first king of the Targaryen dynasty which
lasted for 300 years when he conquered all
of Westeros and united the realm
(with the exception of Dorne and the lands
beyond the Wall)
with 2 sister-wives and their three great
dragons, Balerion, Vhagar and Meraxes.
Aegon's dragon was Balerion the Black Dread,
the largest dragon ever seen in Westeros.
Balerion's jaws were so large that he could
swallow a mammoth.
Aegon was a child of House Targaryen, dwelling
on the island of Dragonstone in the Narrow
Sea.
The Targaryens, a family of Valyrian origin,
had been in control of Dragonstone for a century
before the Doom of Valyria destroyed their
homeland in a volcanic cataclysm.
For another hundred years on Dragonstone,
the Targaryens slowly built up their strength
and raised their dragons, the last in the
world.
Aegon was born on Dragonstone in 27 BC to
Lord Aerion Targaryen and Lady Valaena Velaryon.
All of the previous six generations of Targaryens
born on Dragonstone were the product of incestuous
marriages, but Aerion had no sisters - although
by marrying a Velaryon
he still ensured that his children were of
pure Valyrian descent.
He had an older sister, Visenya, and a younger
sister, Rhaenys.
According to Valyrian and Targaryen tradition,
Aegon married within the family;
however, instead of taking only one sister
to wife, as had been common, he married both
of them.
Aegon was tall, broad-shouldered and powerful
in appearance,
with purple eyes and short-cut silver-gold
hair. He was very charismatic and commanding.
During his Conquest he typically wore a shirt
of black scales into battle
and wielded Valyrian steel sword Blackfyre.
His crown was a simple circlet of Valyrian
steel, set with big square-cut rubies.
Aegon fathered two sons with his sister-wives.
His older son, Aenys, was born to Rhaenys
in 7 AC,
and in 12 AC, Visenya bore his younger son
Maegor, later known as "Maegor the Cruel".
But back to Aegon's early days. The first
major event in his life was helping end the
attempt by Volantis to conquer the other Free
Cities,
using his dragon to support the forces of
Braavos, Tyrosh and the Westerosi Storm King
in driving the Volantenes from Lys and Myr.
In doing so, he confirmed that he had no interest
in reforging a Valyrian empire in Essos.
Aegon then began planning the invasion of
Westeros long before launching the attack,
spending time incognito visiting Westerosi
cities and castles
and gaining intelligence on different houses,
their lords and their vassals.
He was helped in the planning by his half-brother
born out of wedlock, Orys Baratheon,
his most loyal ally and vassal, his best friend
and the first Hand of the King.
When he King of the Stormlands, Argilac the
Arrogant offered Aegon an alliance against
Harren the Black, offering his daughter's
hand in marriage to cement the deal, Aegon
declined
and instead offered Orys's hand in marriage.
Argilac took that as an insult and cut off
the hands of Aegon's envoy.
Aegon used this as a justification for his
invasion of Westeros.
Aegon, his two sister-wives and their three
dragons led a scant few thousand troops in
invading the entire continent of Westeros.
Aegon fortified his initial landing point
at the northern shore of the mouth of the
Blackwater River, strategically very defensible
position protected to the east and south by
water,
and surrounded by open plains which would
expose any attacking army long before it arrived.
Shortly after landing, his sister-wife Visenya
crowned him King of All Westeros and Shield
of His People, titles he later discarded after
his second coronation in Oldtown.
Despite being vastly outnumbered, Aegon was
able to secure victory after victory using
his dragons.
The Targaryen siblings departed the Aegonfort,
with Aegon marching northwest into the riverlands
to confront Harren Hoare. Edmyn Tully, Lord
of Riverrun, declared for Aegon
and led the Riverlords in revolt against the
ruling ironborn.
When Harren refused to yield Harrenhal, Aegon
attacked a gigantic new castle with Balerion,
and House Hoare was extinguished with the
burning of Harrenhal.
The next day Aegon named Edmyn as Lord Paramount
of the Trident.
Meanwhile, Rhaenys and Orys defeated the Durrandons
in the Last Storm,
while Visenya fought the Arryns and secured
the Crackclaw Point.
After regathering at Stoney Sept, the Targaryen
siblings advanced against the larger host
of the Two Kings, King Mern Gardener of the
Reach and King Loren Lannister of the Rock.
The Targaryen dragons (Balerion, Meraxes,
and Vhagar) allowed Aegon to achieve a great
victory at the Field of Fire, which resulted
in the death of Mern IX Gardener, and the
surrender of Loren I Lannister. Aegon then
marched for Highgarden, where he named Harlan
Tyrell as Lord Paramount after the castle's
surrender. The Targaryens again reunited to
face the host of Torrhen Stark, the King in
the North,
but Torrhen chose to kneel to Aegon along
the Trident instead of fighting a battle
and sacrificing dozens of thousands of Northmen
for the lost cause.
Visenya returned to the Vale, where she achieved
the surrender of the Arryns,
while Rhaenys flew to Dorne in an unsuccessful
mission to make the Martells bow.
Aegon, meanwhile, marched to Oldtown, which
was surrendered to him by Lord Manfred Hightower
upon the advice of the High Septon. Within
the Starry Sept, the High Septon declared
Aegon to be the King of the Andals, the Rhoynar,
and the First Men,
Lord of the Seven Kingdoms, and Protector
of the Realm.
Aegon chose to make his seat King's Landing,
a new settlement growing around the Aegonfort.
He took the swords of his defeated enemies,
forging them into the Iron Throne.
Aegon also began what would become known as
the small council,
as well as that of the Hand of the King, with
Lord Orys Baratheon becoming his first Hand.
Aegon's first established law was the King's
Peace,
which forbids conflict in the realm without
the leave of the Iron Throne.
Aegon treated the defeated lords with respect
and allowed each region to retain its own
laws and customs. Aegon often traveled the
realm with six maesters
who educated him on each region's local customs
and history.
In 2 AC, Aegon turned his attention to the
Iron Islands,
where the ironborn had been fighting for two
years over the kingship.
Aegon landed on Great Wyk with Balerion and
a war fleet to deal with the contenders.
Aegon personally cut down Qhorin Volmark with
Blackfyre,
while the priest-king Lodos walked into the
sea, drowning himself.
The other contenders quickly bent the knee.
Aegon allowed the ironborn to name their own
lord paramount,
for which the ironborn chose Vickon Greyjoy
as Lord of the Iron Islands.
Despite a highly successful reign, Aegon did
face considerable problems
and none were as difficult to deal with as
the First Dornish War.
In 3 AC Aegon turned his attention back on
Dorne, the only kingdom remaining unconquered.
He first decided to try and bring Dorne under
the rule of the Iron Throne through diplomacy,
after a year of negotiations and no progress
to show for it although, Aegon decided to
take Dorne by force of arms. In 4 AC Aegon
launched a new invasion, continuing the Wars
of Conquest.
Although initially the conquest of Dorne seemed
to succeed, it unraveled quickly
and the First Dornish War prolonged and lasted
for nine years, and knew many deaths and tragedies.
One of these tragedies was the capture and
mutilation of Aegon's friend and Hand of the
King,
Lord Orys Baratheon, by the Wyl of Wyl.
Following his release from two years of captivity,
Orys returned home lacking a swordhand.
Aegon, intent on revenge, released his dragons
and burned the castles of defiant Dornish
lords.
In 7 AC, Aegon became a father for the first
time, when his younger sister-wife Rhaenys
gave birth to a son: Aenys.
The greatest loss Aegon faced was the death
of Queen Rhaenys Targaryen at Hellholt in
10 AC,
when Meraxes fell from the sky (with Rhaenys
upon her back)
after a shot from a scorpion took the dragon
in the eye.
The war took a different turn after this.
Aegon's fury and grief at the loss of his
wife was such that he headed for Dorne himself.
Accompanied by Visenya, the last two Targaryens
rained fire upon the desert strongholds
to break the Dornish. The next two years were
known as the Dragon's Wroth,
a period when every Dornish castle felt the
fury of the dragonriders.
The only castle spared was Sunspear, the seat
of House Martell,
in hopes that the Dornish would turn against
their liege lords.
The strategy failed and Dorne remained unconquered.
In 11 AC, Queen Visenya announced her pregnancy,
and the next year she gave birth to Aegon's
second son, Maegor.
When Princess Meria Martell died in 13 AC,
her son, Prince Nymor, sued for peace, having
grown weary of war.
He sent his daughter, Deria with the skull
of Meraxes and a letter with her, to King's
Landing to treat with the Conqueror.
The peace demanded by Dorne was peace between
two sovereign kingdoms, not between a liege
and his vassal. Although Aegon heard her out
(against the advice of his advisors, such
as Orys and Visenya), he apparently decided
to refuse the request for peace.
Before he could speak, Deria mounted the Iron
Throne and placed the letter from her father
in his hand. What was in the letter is unknown,
but Aegon's hand was so clenched around it
that it started to bleed. He burned the letter
and left on Balerion for Dragonstone.
The next morning, he returned and signed the
peace treaty proposed by the Prince of Dorne,
recognizing it as a sovereign kingdom.
Historians suspect that Nymor had revealed
to Aegon that Rhaenys was still alive and
badly injured from falling off Meraxes and
that he would end her suffering if the Conqueror
agreed to peace.
However I do not believe this to be true
because Aegon kept good relations with Princess
Deria afterward.
Perhaps his sister survived the fall and she
delivered her to Aegon on Dragonstone.
He even visited Sunspear with his eldest son,
Prince Aenys, in 23 AC
to celebrate the tenth anniversary of the
peace between the Iron Throne and Dorne.
Anyways, the Conqueror was almost killed by
assassins in the streets of King's Landing
and was only saved by Visenya. This led to
creation of the Kingsguard,
with its first members chosen by Visenya to
protect her brother-husband with their lives.
The remaining twenty-four years of Aegon's
reign were peaceful,
so much that the last two decades of his reign
were later called the Dragon's Peace,
by the maesters of the Citadel. He spent much
of his time consolidating his power by traveling
throughout the Seven Kingdoms and building
his capital at King's Landing.
In 37 AC on Dragonstone, while telling his
two eldest grandsons Aegon and Viserys the
tales of his conquest at the Painted Table,
Aegon died from a stroke at the age of sixty-four.
Aegon was cremated on Dragonstone, and his
funeral pyre was set aflame by Vhagar.
Blackfyre was burned along with him, but later
retrieved from the pyre by Maegor.
That is the story of a legendary, ear-mythical
figure, Aegon the Conqueror.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Once again, House of the Dragon, a Game of
Thrones prequel about House Targaryen is coming
in 2022 on HBO.
Thank you so much for watching, if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs up
and I hope to see you in the next one.
Peace!